this is just asking questions a show for
inquiring minds un
reason today's guest is Stella Assange
an attorney specializing in
international law a human rights
activist and the wife of WikiLeaks
founder juliia Assange with whom she has
two children Stella thank you for
talking with us today thanks for having
me Julian nange was arrested out
England's Ecuadorian Embassy after his
political Asylum was revoked and moved
to bmarsh prison in April 2019 and
that's a maximum security facility where
inmates are held in small single cells
Amnesty International has drawn
parallels to Guantanamo Bay uh reports
and statements from doctors emerged
quickly after that imprisonment
testifying to his deteriorating mental
and physical health how was he doing
today um well as we filmed this um we're
nearing his fifth uh year his fifth uh
Christmas in belmarsh Prison and he has
been there uh for over four and a half
years now uh because the US is trying to
extradite him since the 11th of April
2019 and he hasn't left the facility um
to go to court since January 2021 that
was the last time they allowed him to
come to court to his own hearings uh
since then uh he's been participating
remotely over video link because they
don't let him to even go to the
courtroom uh his uh physical state has
obviously deterior deteriorated over
that time he spends um a lot of time in
his cell uh but he is able to receive
visits so once or twice a week I can go
and see him on weekends I can bring the
kids
um and that obviously helps him a lot he
can call me from belar prison uh during
certain hours throughout the day uh so
we uh are in contact UM ongoingly during
the day for most days unless there's
some kind of problem and that obviously
keeps him uh sane and um helps us both
uh you know um feel like we're not so
separated and
apart
um what can you I mean I imagine this is
you know you're you're a mother you you
have kids together um you know H how
often are you actually able to travel
and see him and kind of what is the
personal situation like for you well
it's obviously very difficult um our
children are uh the oldest one is six
and a half and the youngest one will
turn five in February and uh they all
their memories of Julian are inside this
one big visiting Hall inside Bel Marsh
prison and I you know I I uh reiterate
that Julian is only there um because
there is this extradition request from
the US he's not charged of any crime in
the UK um they're just holding him on
behalf of the United States that is
opposing baale and so we have to um
we're forced to uh interact with in this
extremely harsh environment and that's
how the children that's all the children
know um visiting uh their father inside
a a big loud monitored uh visiting
Hall once a week more or less how do you
explain to the children like was there
ever a time when you sort of explained
what was going on and contextualized the
children why their father is in this
type of environment like how much do
they know or is this just the only thing
they've ever
known um well it's it's really a mix of
the two so I've tried to introduce
context as they grow older I didn't want
them to understand what a prison was
before um before other Concepts like you
know freedom and fairness um but uh so
actually it was our eldest son Gabriel
at one point I guess he was around five
or yeah it must have been around five
where he asked whether um whether julan
was in prison this place that we went to
was it a prison and I told him yes uh
before that I would say we're going to
the big building where daddy is and it's
not daddy's home he's just being kept
there and obviously they experienced the
whole um process of going through the
prison security which is everyone has to
go through it you know everyone
including toddlers uh have to be
searched by the dogs they look inside
their mouths and so on uh they get
padded down um so they're they've seen
that and they live it and um eventually
um yeah the eldest one asked me if this
was a prison and I explained that yes
it's a prison but that Daddy hasn't done
anything wrong in fact um he's done good
things and he's being punished by bad
people obviously you know I'm trying to
explain it in age appropriate way
uh and also trying to also uh counter
the
um you know the immediate horror of the
situation with the fact that lots of
people support Julian and are fighting
for his freedom and sometimes I've taken
them to protests and so on so that they
actually see that there are a lot of
people that support Julian and that
actually there's something bigger going
on and it's not just um he's just not
he's not just any other prisoner and
that's obvious from when you VIs visit
Bel Marsh there's you know um huge
banners saying free Julian Assange there
are protests which we see um often
there's uh at least once a week There's
a protest people going into the prison
into the prison premises uh with
loudspeakers and calling for him to be
release and all the visitors all the
family members and friends who go and
visit their uh the prisoners that are
inside see it as well so um obviously
this isn't something that the other
prisoners have this is a a unique case
and they they they can sense that
there's something special about their
dad um and I've you know I've I've
explained it in different ways um I've
told them you know it's not that the
guards themselves who they see and
interact with are holding their father
uh specifically it's the you know it's
it's the people above them the people
who decide and they're the people that
Julian um made angry because he showed
them um he he showed the world that they
had done bad things and they're angry
about that um and uh that's that's
generally how I I try to explain it um
and they understand um I tell them
Daddy's a hero millions of people around
the world admire him he spoke the truth
and sometimes it's difficult to tell the
truth uh a lot of people will get angry
and try to take revenge but but um it's
it's important
and um and that's what that's what
Julian did well so you you first met
Julian if I'm not mistaken um when he
was fighting sexual assault charges uh
in Sweden and you you initially joined
his his defense team what made you
interested in that case and what's your
perspective on that whole
case well I joined his legal team in
February 2011 and uh the so Julian had
started public lishing the Wikileaks uh
Publications uh from that had been sent
to WikiLeaks by Chelsea Manning in 2010
so a year before I joined his team and
so these Publications from Chelsea
Manning which were uh the collateral
murder video um the Iraq War logs
Afghanistan war
Diaries um diplomatic cables and wantan
Bay files and these are the same
Publications that Julian is indicted
with um indicted over now uh that had
happened uh in the leadup to um me
joining his legal team and it had also
started uh prior to any preliminary
investigation being opened in Sweden and
actually there were never any charges in
Sweden and none were brought and that's
quite amazing because um it kind of
defies logic right because there was a
big extradition cas case and um Sweden
would say well we haven't decided
whether to actually bring charges
against him but we just want to question
him and then um there was this question
about well why don't you just question
him because in you know hundreds of
other cases uh the Sweden would travel
to other European countries to question
him and so on anyway that Swedish
preliminary
investigation um was uh dropped and
resurrected multiple times it was
dropped for times resurrected three um
no charges were ever brought uh
the it's quite extraordinary I mean the
the
um the amazing thing about this case is
that the prosecutor was refusing to
question him and you think how can it
possibly be that in a in a sex case
where of course memories fade and and it
all depends on you know um the
Recollections of of the the people
involved and so on that the prosecutor
um had to be compelled by the Swedish
court of appeal uh six years after the
fact um to question him and uh the
reason the court of appeal compelled her
was she said uh that she had failed her
her um professional duty to um Advance
the case and of course this is just one
um aspect of how that Swedish
preliminary investigation was abusive
and the reason it was abusive was
because it was um it took place in
a highly charged uh political moment in
which Julian was being um actively um
sought by uh authorities because he was
about to publish um the Chelsea mining
Lakes it had already published the
collateral murder video and the Afghan
warlocks and then it was one months um
before uh Wikileaks started publishing
the Iraq
warlocks um that he went to Sweden
there's actually a Daily Beast article
uh it's archived it's it's no longer on
the website but it's archived in which
uh the US uh the reporter says that
state department was contacting its
allies in Europe um and urging them to
find a way to stop Julian and his tracks
to arrest him on whatever um because
they had by then they had arrested uh
Chelsea uh Manning then Bradley Manning
um and they knew that Wikileaks had more
major uh leaks coming out and so they
wanted to stop him in his tracks they
contacted the Australians the
Australians were looking to cancel his
passport and then there was an
investigation by the Australian police
and then the Australian police
recommended not canceling his passport
because it would be easier to track his
movements and ultimately um uh Sweden in
initiated this preliminary investigation
which was um condemned by the United
Nations is an abuse against Julian's um
rights as a defendant he was in fact
never a formally a defendant because he
was never charged which meant that he
was never given access to exculpatory
evidence of text messages that we knew
existed um and so the UN special
reporter on torture also did an
investigation in 2019 wrote to the
Swedish and UK governments um who ref
refused to um cooperate he wrote a whole
book about it it's called the trials of
Julian Assange and for um any viewers
who are interested in this kind of
Swedish um uh preliminary investigation
which also served to um you know cast a
shadow on Julian um to treat him as uh
an accused person without being formally
accused and so on uh there are two key
books one is by this special reporter on
torture Neil Meltzer and it's called the
trial of Julian Assange and then there's
another one called um Wikileaks and its
enemies
uh by Stefan maritti which is a Italian
um investigative journalist and she's
done actually these two books are very
complimentary because um the one by the
special
reporter um involves his own
investigation into um the reports his uh
Communications with the governments in
in a formal manner you know a a un
official and uh Stefania marici as an
investigative journalist she has done a
lot of foil work and
obtained um a bunch of uh correspondents
some of which had been destroyed by one
party which is the UK government um
which is incredibly damning and it shows
how in fact there was a collusion
between the UK and Sweden um that this
the UK was tell telling Sweden not to
question him to extradite him to put him
in and and the Sweden was going to put
him in custody immediately um and um
urging them not to progress the
investigation unless he was
extradited uh and of course this is this
is um extremely bizarre and and
um unjust of course um denying a suspect
the ability to defend himself but of
course if you
if you think this is um just a regular
case then uh none of it makes sense but
you once you understand um the political
context then of course it all makes
sense and it even says in this
correspondence that Stefania maritti
discovered uh literally the sentence
please do not think that we are treating
this as just any other extradition case
that's the words of the uh UK um
prosecution Authority who was uh
communicating with the Swedish
authorities and then when Sweden tried
to drop it in
2013 um the UK responded pleas uh don't
you dare get cold feet um telling them
not to drop it so uh it's pretty clear I
mean it's very clear now two two you
know extremely uh detailed uh exhaustive
examinations about um the Swedish uh
preliminary
investigation and as I said for which
Julian was never charged uh but of
course as soon as that was dropped um
was revealed that there was uh a an
indictment that had come under the Trump
Administration and Julian has been um in
belmarsh uh in relation to that
extradition request from the US since
2019 so I want to get into the
extradition request in a moment but I am
curious so you're basically saying
Sweden was engaged in a politically
motivated Witch Hunt of Julian but the
thing that I'm also curious about is you
know these are uh not the traditional
circumstances under which most people
meet their spouses um what was this like
for you emotionally was this this sense
of I mean most of the time when you meet
somebody who becomes your husband
they're not you know being accused of
rape uh in another country um how did
you feel signing up to work on this case
and then getting to know Julian like
what was swirling around in your
head well I was um steeped in the in the
um document surrounding this uh Swedish
preliminary
investigation and um there was no case
to answer from the beginning it was
pretty clear that the uh administrative
use of the extradition uh request from
Sweden uh was a way to uh trap him
basically to bury him in uh legal um
quagar uh in order to interfere with his
publishing work I mean in Sweden as I
said like the the initial prosecutor who
uh looked at the case said there there
is no um crime of rape involved in these
allegations um but the Swedish um look
the Swedish uh conduct in this case also
responds to uh local Dynamics uh the the
person who took on the case within days
um was also running for for um
uh there were general elections in
Sweden he was tipped to become the new
uh justice
Minister um Julian's case was in the
media there were a lot of motivations it
wasn't just the uh you know possible
nudge or likely nudge from the state
department at the highest levels uh
Julian um Julian's name was was leaked
to the Press uh which should never
happen in the case of a preliminary
investigation where the person has
doesn't even be formally accused and as
I said he was never formally accused in
those 9 years um the un uh working group
on arbitrary detention which looked at
this case from 2014 onwards um
saw uh the um underlying investigation
material it was an adversarial process
in which Sweden and the UK um also
participated and were unsuccessful in
convincing this um group of UN expt on
arbitrary detention um that they had
conducted themselves in a lawful manner
they had in fact violated International
obligations concerning arbitrary
detention when it came to Julian because
as I said he was neither convicted or
even charged in relation to Sweden um
and so it was this extraordinary abusive
nature of the Swedish
allegations um that was immediately
obvious to me as uh a member of his
legal legal team but also as a Swedish
speaker because I'm fluent in Swedish
and so I could directly access the um um
the material of the case uh that we had
access to to see that this was absurd
and my own experience I mean as I got to
know Julian was to see how he was uh
persecuted and um maligned in all sorts
of ways of course the Swedish aspect was
just one it was an effective one because
uh Julian had a lot of support from the
left uh initially um because these
Publications concerned of course the
bush Wars and so on and uh sex case um
even one without a formal accusation or
a conviction or anything uh obviously is
going to alienate
um a portion of the left um and and uh a
big portion of women um and there was a
deliberate uh strategy as as these foyer
documents show to keep him in this uh
position of not being able to defend
himself of not being able to um you know
clear his name because they refused to
question him um Sweden refused to give
an a guarantee that he wouldn't be
onward Le extradited to the US and
Sweden in fact you know in spite of its
um its
reputation uh was a participant in the
CIA rendition um
uh program it rendered um agiza and um
aleri to Asylum Seekers who were in the
process of applying for protection and
instead they were taking on a CIA flight
and tortured in Egypt and um this was
one of the most obvious um one of the
most shocking cases of CIA rendition
concerned Sweden and in fact since 2001
uh Sweden I don't know if it's still
true but definitely while Julian was
still um um facing um potential
extradition to Sweden Sweden has not
once rejected an extradition request to
the United States and this is different
to the UK which has it's it's rare but
has rejected extradition requests to the
United States so this was also a factor
in in uh Julian's decision to resist
extradition to to Sweden which is a very
small country and Views itself as a very
small country uh certainly in relation
to the US Britain has the similar
similar mentality but Sweden you can't
even compare yeah you you've laid out
lots of reasons to be skeptical of the
Sweden sex case against Assange and I
mean I would think that any objective
Observer looking at what has happened to
him the way he was extradited kind of
immediately or sorry not extra uh
imprisoned immediately after the Asylum
was lifted should at least make you
raise an eyebrow
as to what was going on there but um I I
want to raise a couple of criticisms uh
that that you hear commonly um you know
one comes from the intelligence
community in the United States
government officials which we can get to
that later but first while we're on this
topic one thing that you hear a lot from
people who are more friendly to
WikiLeaks you know Wikileaks as you
mentioned was kind of embraced on the
American left and then kind of fell out
of favor um there's people who were or
are friendly to its mission who say that
Julian Assange is he's a problematic
figure he's kind of an egomaniac who
puts his personal legal troubles and
grudges above the mission of the
organization it's a theme that you see
in multiple documentaries produced about
him including Risk by Laura pois who's
sympathetic but sort of takes this
position that you know Julian's personal
troubles are are intertwined too much
with Wikileaks Mission what do you make
of that kind of
criticism well it's it's really a dated
criticism because that kind of criticism
came about when the extradition case in
relation to Sweden was alive um when a
lot of facts concerning the Swedish um
extradition
the fact that he wasn't even charged the
fact that you know all this foyer
documentation that we now know and which
is now in the public domain um had come
out and so on and so a lot of people at
the time were saying well he has nothing
to worry about the US doesn't want to
extradite him this is all about Sweden
Etc and unfortunately um risk is um fell
into that trap uh it's very dated now
when you watch it because uh obviously
what happened was that uh Julian was
indicted in relation to um the Afghan
and Iraq war Publications and so on and
uh look a lot of these um uh portrayals
came about in the immediate aftermath of
these Publications so what
happened um in 2010
2011 uh was that Wikileaks came onto the
scene um and broke more significant
stories
um by then the Legacy press had um you
know in in 50 years combined um and of
course wikix had partnered with uh the
New York Times the guardian and uh three
major European papers as well in Germany
Spain um and France and to to kind of
maximize the uh the coverage of these
big
databases um and so they would publish
the the cables the war logs and so on in
coordination um doing joint
investigations and so on uh with these
big papers once the big papers had
published together with Wikileaks then
there wasn't much utility in that
partnership and they dist distance
themselves and Julian was also a Critic
of the way that these major papers um
reported on the Wikileaks Publications
the way they redacted information that
exposed them uh perhaps to um lawsuits
from oligarchs uh whereas uh the content
was um of such significance that that um
and also you know Wikileaks had already
published on their website so there was
from that perspective um no um uh
serious uh legal threat um but so Julian
has been you know a media critic he has
been critic uh
critic critical of um the major media
players and of course he was an outsider
he's Australian um this is a an internet
publisher um an internet publisher that
attracted very high quality sources who
entrusted Wikileaks as the V
with which um this information could
reach uh the public and the reason for
that was that Wikileaks had uh and has a
pretty much um well a a a very um
highgrade um submission system which has
since been
um
um kind of copied by by the mainstream
there's a very interesting paper by by
um Jack Goldsmith who was the who is a
former assistant um attorney general
under uh Republican Administration I
can't remember which called the
Wikileaks iation of the American Press
and what he argues is uh that actually
the American
Press adopted the innovations that
Wikileaks had um
pioneered by the mid um uh 2010s right
um The New York Times Washington Post
the guardian Etc they all have the same
or similar technology they adopted the
technology that Wikileaks invented um
for the um submission of using uh
encryption to be able to protect sources
when they communicate and also uh the
submission systems so that you don't
necessarily as uh the receiver of
information know who the source was and
provide the source with sufficient um um
um encryption so um knowledge to be able
to mask um their identity and so this
became uh a adopted by the mainstream
press another Innovation that Wikileaks
brought was to to create Partnerships um
between media organizations it was
Wikileaks who basically forced the New
York Times to cooperate with the
guardian to cooperate with lamond and
ELP and so on it had never been done
before it wasn't easy and um part of the
reason why um the there was um uh you
know a a distancing uh from Julian I
think was because uh they they didn't
like to work um in a way that was not on
their own terms even when it was with
other major um major U Media Partners
and so when Julian um came onto the
scene he was seen as a as a um
competitor but also as a threat to the
mainstream media's
um economic model you know this is like
2010 so the the media was only just kind
of um the major papers were were
publishing online um their their
advertising Revenue was down people
weren't buying papers anymore and they
were like how are they going to survive
lots of people are being fired and so on
and here comes
Wikileaks uh that has a completely
different business model which is uh
it's small uh has a lot of
volunteers um and uh and it's reader
funded and of course now we see reader
funded um Publications quite a lot but
at the time um you know apart from some
bloggers perhaps but this was a read
reader funded publication that was
unfettered by
advertising um you know restrictions and
so on and that at the same time was
having such high quality sources uh come
to to them and having high impact and
enabling it to enter into Partnerships
with the biggest media organizations the
med biggest media houses and basically
being able to call the shots because
Wikileaks was the one that attracted the
sources and of course um once the um the
legal trouble started and the financial
blockade um Bank of America PayPal
Western Union and so on blocked uh the
donations to WikiLeaks as soon as
Wikileaks had started to publish the
state department cables this was also
the time when Julian was arrested over
the Swedish um allegations this all
happened within a week um so it all came
down at the same time and then these
major media organizations who had
partnered with Wikileaks um then turned
against Julian and basically I think I
think the objective was to try to kill
off Wikileaks because because it was a
competitor because um uh it has had had
such an important impact and was a
newcomer and uh a a threat to the kind
of gate gatekeeper function that we all
know um we do have a we have a a montage
of some MSNBC hosts reacting to Assange
I was wondering if you roll that Zack um
and then we'd love to get your reaction
I have a follow-up question after
that many establishment journalists in
the US consider Julian Assange to be a
criminal whose work doesn't fit in the
same category as their own no journalism
here what we have is an act of Espionage
the wholesale dumping of WikiLeaks
actually isn't journalism if you help in
the stealing of classified material
nothing about the first amendment is
going to insulate you from charging that
you stole regardless of whether or not
you publish it I mean you learned that
day one in news business
school I find this whole montage very
funny because we've actually seen this
sort of reiterated um you know basically
from this time all the way up until now
I mean it's still a thing that people
talk about maybe not with the specific
Espionage framing but there's this line
drawn between well these people are
journalists over here but these other
people surely don't qualify and so
therefore their first amendment
protections ought to be different how
how do you feel when you see you know
MSNBC hosts treating Julian Assange this
way
Stella well I mean it's it's kind of
um it's a bit disappointing because the
criticisms that they um use are just
simply not true um you had uh Maria
ressa there she she was a CNN um
presenter and then and um uh she's a
Nobel priest Prize winner and has
herself um faced political prosecution
because of her journalism and it's
really disappointing uh that she says
something like uh Wikileaks dumping this
is one of the um major U
Mis uh say distortions concerning
Wikileaks uh Wikileaks does privilege U
the publication of archives but it
doesn't just dump it's uh you know it
provides
context it writes up context uh it
writes up analyses um it it um has
redacted uh information and states the
the criteria for redactions and so on um
but even so I mean all of this is really
irrelevant whether Julian's a journalist
or not the question is is Julian accused
of Journalism and he is it is the
activity that has been criminalized um
not um whether he falls into a category
or not uh it's the category of the
activity that is being criminalized uh
receiving obtaining and uh communicating
information to the public and you know
the use of the Espionage Act it's it's
uh very interesting because you see kind
of lazy
journalists uh lazy reporters
lazy sometimes I think it's it's also
deliberate right uh talking about Julian
as if he is being um accused of being a
spy now this is of course you enter into
the realm of
absurdity uh when when you start talking
about uh the the allegations against
Julian because the first point is that
Julian is
Australian um he's not American he's
never lived there um and the use of the
Espionage Act allows for this kind of um
laziness C categorical laziness um and
that's because the Espionage Act it's a
very broadly worded indeterminate piece
of text that was adopted in
1917 um and that has been interpreted in
an increasingly expansive way and uh
especially under the Obama
Administration you have uh for the
first well actually
um it had been used against journalistic
sources but in in in quite a selective
manner before uh the Obama
Administration the Obama Administration
really ramped up the use of the
Espionage Act against journalistic
sources um and there's no allegation
that those that there was some kind of
foreign power involved uh rather that
these were um uh newspapers TVs whatever
that were receiving information from
from the person accused under the
Espionage Act and um under the Obama
Administration um three times uh
the um three times more people were
prosecuted as sources of um of uh uh
news stories then all previous
administrations in the 100 years that
preceding it preceded it combined and so
um this expansive Trend that started
with the Obama Administration then uh
continued and became even more extreme
under the Trump Administration so it
actually uh took the US 8 years to bring
an indictment against Julian and it came
under the um Trump Administration
actually just before this um I don't
mean to read much here I just found this
quote that was really interesting so um
there was a case called the Morrison
case in 1984 and this was a source who
was um um indicted and convicted under
the uh Espionage Act for disclosing
classified photos to a British military
journal and um there was uh judge Harvey
Wilkinson who in his concurring
opinion um said that this would be
limited to uh the role of the source
because press organizations are not
being and probably could not be
prosecuted under the Espionage Act
because the political Firestorm that
would
follow uh prosecution of one who exposed
an administration's own inaptitude would
make such prosecutions an unrealistic
Prospect so in other ways in other words
he was saying that what limits the
Espionage Act is political safeguards it
is the the outcry it is the reaction to
um the Preposterous use of the Espionage
Act against the press and so what has
happened is that the Espionage Act has
been used in that way it's been used
against Julian its precedent setting and
uh the supposed outcry That was supposed
to limit this kind of use of the
Espionage Act has not followed yeah
although I I do think there have been an
increasing number of journalists
especially people in National Security
reporting who have been awakened to the
they they realize the implications of
what happens if there is a successful
prosecution against Julian Assange I
think with some of these msnpc hosts a
lot of this is uh tied up with what
happened in the 2016 election uh
Wikileaks involvement with the DNC
emails um there's uh you know that
Hillary Clinton has positioned has said
uh uh has positioned herself kind of the
chief rival of uh Julian Assange and and
Assange had not too kind for uh her
either um you know uh Mike Pompeo who uh
was serving as the CI Chief under uh
Trump was the one who labeled Wikileaks
a um kind of hostile intelligent
non-state hostile intelligence
service this all all that unfolded in
2016 between Wikileaks uh and uh the US
government during the election um How do
you think that changed the tenor of the
conversation and the way that people
view
Wikileaks um and what do you say to
people who do get a suspicious feeling
who think that there's some weird
relationship between Julian Assange and
Russia I mean you know there like he had
a show on Russia Today for a while there
have been some Russians who've worked
for
Wikileaks um should people be suspicious
I don't think there are any Russians who
have worked for
Wikileaks um Wikileaks uh well Julian
had a talk show um that was licensed to
a number of channels and uh Russia Today
at the time this was 2011 I mean you
this is a long time ago this is like 13
years ago um had the license for
Julian's talk show which is also
available on YouTube because it was also
licensed to others um and um that was
the extent of his involvement with any
um you know he licensed a show it was a
UK production company that he owned um
so um the these allegations have never
been substantiated because there is no
nothing to
substantiate uh the uh Mueller report of
course uh came up with nothing um
the naal security directors in January
2017 already uh during a um
Congressional hearing uh said that in
relation to the 2016 election material
they had no um no evidence of any
anything um onto uh concerning Wikileaks
um you know it's it's all been uh
speculation it's all basically coming
down to Julian licensed a show to RT in
2011 um it's it's it's weak to say the
least of course in relation to the 2016
Publications there was a strategy by the
Hillary campaign to um talk about uh
Russia is allegedly um interfering with
that El election and so on but taken uh
when you look at the Wikileaks
Publications specifically
um that had you know nothing to do with
this other stuff the DC leaks and I
don't know what um which others did
publish uh like
um the hill and others published stuff
that they said they got from this
character gfer 2o um that's separate to
um what what wikix published which was
uh the DNC leaks and the podesta emails
and earlier in the year they had they
had also republished
um
the um Hillary Clinton emails that had
been put up on the state department
website but which were not easily
accessible so there were actually three
Clinton
Publications um so the DNC ones uh
revealed how the Hillary CL Hillary
Clinton campaign had rigged uh the
Democratic primaries and basically
defrauded um the Democratic
um um donors who were being misled that
U at least the Bernie ones who were
being misled that their candidate that
they were supporting actually had a
chance of becoming a nominee um so uh
the Hillary CL campaign of course
afterwards one found out that uh in
Donna Brazil's book uh that there was a
secret agreement between the DNC and the
Hillary CL campaign um and there was it
was even a written agement and uh that
they were colluding basically to
undermine and uh uh ensure that Bernie
Sanders did not get the equal um did not
get access to the media and and so on um
and then the podesta emails which came
in October were uh showed how the
Hillary Clint campaign had also um
basically rigged the um um the
Republican um uh primaries in the sense
that they had this thing called the P
Piper strategy in which they would get
their mates in the
uh MSNBC and so on to get Trump on the
airwaves because according to the
Hillary
campaign uh their view was that um Trump
and a couple of other Republican
candidates which they viewed as extreme
and um
unelectable uh would alienate the swing
voters and so on and that if they if
they gave Trump air time and if they
convinced their allies in the press to
give Trump airtime then Hillary would
win and of course we knew uh what
happened after that so these were you
know incredibly important and uh
Publications and in fact there was a
court case that um many people haven't
even heard about the DNC tried to um
actually um tried to sue uh Wikileaks
and Julian personally in New York in the
southern district of New York uh in
relation to the DNC Publications and
that uh case was thrown out by the judge
on First Amendment grounds and in fact
he said that this was uh the type of
publication that uh enjoys the highest
protection of the First Amendment
because you cannot think of a more
important um uh publication than that
concerning uh political candidates and
the lead up to an election that is of
the highest you know significance for
the public to know about um and then so
uh that's a really important and strong
judgment the New York Times afterwards
gave a a um interview to the to the BBC
saying well if they had received it they
would have also published it and in fact
talking about who the possible source is
is irrelevant if the material is of um
the significance that that uh these
these Publications actually had but of
course I think it I it raises important
questions about whether it's really
possible in the US media landscape to be
truly independent can you alienate
Democrats and Republicans and still um
and still
enjoy uh protection you know under even
under the law like the political heat on
you and on wik leaks having published
damning information both about
Republicans and post 2016 about
Democrats has has placed Julian in an
extremely vulnerable position uh
vulnerable in in the sense that if the
protections if the First Amendment
protections are not robust enough if the
political climate is such um where there
is a a push for censorship a push um for
propaganda for uh um you know repression
uh when it comes to speech uh then then
uh these this political restraint that
that um I was talking about earlier on
the Espionage Act becomes
ineffective I want to take us back in
time to 2010 for a second um which was
when wikileak
made its first big release with the
collateral murder video which showed you
know a 2007 I guess US air strike in
Baghdad killing you know a dozen over a
dozen civilians uh and really expose
some of the horrors of that war to an
American audience for the first time
what was the impact of that video and
what has the broader impact of WikiLeaks
releas has been on the world and
actually before you answer that Stella
we have a clip from a documentary I
produced on uh assange's plight where
he's reflecting on that that video which
made a huge Splash and was really
Wikileaks introduction to the world I
like to roll that clip and get some of
his thoughts and then get you to you
know add any meat onto that so let's
roll that real
quick light them all
up come on
fire Wikileaks would title collateral
murder showed footage from a US Army
Apache helicopter of soldiers gunning
down more than a dozen people in Baghdad
who weren't engaged in active combat
including two Reuters reporters the
video generated International press and
controversy Assange said his intention
was to expose the Casual Carnage and
destruction happening in the course of
the US war in Iraq it was the another
day at the office how routine it was a
whole street covered with bodies the
reaction to that you're
was and so as we've you've made very
clear in this interview the the the
charges against Assange have nothing to
do with all these rumors swirling around
what happened in 2016 it's about the
release of these documents in 2010 uh
including this video um what was the
import of the collateral murder
video well it really marks a before and
an after uh concerning the bush Wars uh
this had it's 2010 right this actual um
uh event depicted in the video is I
believe from July 20 uh
2007 and so the war had started in 2003
um and it had been going for seven years
by the time collateral murder was
released and by then there wasn't you
know much interest in the media anymore
more there were embedded
journalists uh traveling you know with
with us convoys and going to press
briefings by the Pentagon and so on um
but there was no real insight um there
were just body bags coming back from
Iraq um and uh and there was no like
real um uh news worthiness let's say in
reporting about Iraq and then suddenly
this came um down uh and it had such an
impact because it really
contrasted with what uh with the curated
um uh information uh that was coming
through the media and it and it it was
it depicts a war crime that's that's
what you see it's it's not just the
Gunning down of these individuals to
begin with where a um two Reuters
journalists are on assignment and and
get killed one of them crawls tries to
crawl uh to to cover and then a van
pulls up and um two Good Samaritans come
out of the van and try to um pick pick
up this uh journalist and then bring him
into the van and then it gets shoot shot
down um and everyone dies except for two
children who are um shielded by the body
of their father uh so this is a a truly
horrific um video and it's horrific not
just because you're watching it but
because you're you're listening to the
conversation and the kind of um
uh uh jokey conversation around this and
so on and it's it it's become um to the
Iraq War what that picture of the of the
Napal girl you know in Vietnam um is to
the Vietnam War the one where she's
walking she's running um naked away for
the village that has just been naped um
it is uh I think Chelsea Manning has
said that it is like in in in 30 minutes
you see just the the concentration the
um Iraq war in its Essence and it really
captured the international um the
international imagination and in 2011
December 2011 uh Obama
um Obama had by then the the uh Obama's
um sorry the US military had had been um
removed officially at least uh from Iraq
um in in big in a big part because of
what weix had published including there
was another report in one of the cables
about a family that was massacred and um
and the evidence of that event had then
been destroyed by a US air strike and um
all of the members including five
children under the age of five had had
bullets in their head and and it was a
US Air Raid in the middle of the night
in a village in Iraq um so these
Wikileaks had a major impact in um in
the way uh US policy um developed after
that point of the publication of the
collateral murder video um
and you know also with the Afghan war it
took another 10 years or nine years for
that to finish and we all know how that
ended um but it it didn't just show the
Carnage in Iraq but the senselessness of
sending um soldiers to fight this this
war in Iraq and dying and getting
injured and of course the epidemic of
suicides that that has followed and is
ongoing right um so it has a major I
mean it can't be uh overstated uh how
important it's very it's just very
telling to me that this is what the US
is Prosecuting him over is facilitating
the release of undeniably true
information about the war that the US
was Prosecuting so that the people could
have a clearer vision of what was going
on and it clearly had an impact on
people's view o of that war and for Me
Julian Assange is a figure of world
historical importance because of what he
unlocked with Wikileaks I mean he
demonstrated undeniably that the
Strategic use of Technology like
encryption would be Shifting the entire
Global power structure and he ushered in
that new reality really it it it was the
reality that the cipher Punk movement
dreamed of of this world where a small
team of hackers and activists can just
share information and even the most
powerful governments can't do anything
to stop the release of that information
and he pushed it into being and showed a
whole generation that maybe resistance
to these powerful superstates actually
isn't feudal and um if you have the
right tools and you know how to use
them you can really change the world and
I think that might be a big part of why
he's a Marked Man more so than his
alleged crimes um but is there anything
else to say that you want to say as
we're wrapping up about his significance
as a cipher Punk or kind of his place in
history um well I think um Julian is a
is a Visionary and a pioneer as you say
uh his writings and his speeches many of
his speeches or or Clips have gone viral
uh on the internet you know in relation
to Ukraine for example he was talking
talking about Afghanistan but um his
kind of big picture analysis and uh
criticism of of the um drivers of war
the true drivers of War um have uh
currency now and in fact you know I I uh
often go back to things that he wrote 10
years ago um because they are they have
stood the test of time and um you know
he is he is a a global um figure and um
a thinker of our times and the type that
that uh is is darely
needed um so you know Julian has to be
freed not just because this is an
enormous Injustice and the the precedent
it sets um affects journalists
everywhere in the US um but also
globally um it's an extreme overreach it
uh criminalizes uh the publication of
true information um of the highest
public importance but also because of
Julian's uh position as a public
intellectual and of someone who promotes
uh truth and um and is a Critic of of
War um
and uh just I'm not sure when this is
airing but um there's a a house
resolution currently
um which is being pushed which has been
uh tabled I think that's the word they
use in the US I don't know by Paul goar
um that says um expressing the sense of
house the House of Representatives that
regular journalistic activities are
protected under the First Amendment and
that the US ought to drop Char all
charges and attempts to extradite Julian
Assange and there there's also a uh a
letter that's been signed by multiple
congressmen including Thomas Massie who
we interviewed last week uh asking Biden
to do the same thing to drop the
extradition so to to wrap this up can
you tell me like are you optimistic that
there will be some sort of shift in the
political winds that this some something
can change for Julian's case like how
are you feeling at the end of the day
here well I think that um politicians
that actually take the time or at least
their um their staffers that take the
time to look at this case will
immediately understand the dangers and
the unamerican nature I mean really the
the first amendment is something that is
quite unique in the world and it defines
the political culture of the United
States which is much more open and
dynamic than other parts of the world
Europe for sure um and this case is
actually kind of
a a a more europeanized more um not to
talk down Europe too much but it is uh
no totalitarian in its nature and it
changes it shifts the political culture
and it has to be reversed and I think
any um you know the vast majority of uh
politicians that look at this case
seriously will be will understand um
that the dangers of this case that it
should never come uh to pass um that the
case should be
dropped and I'd ask uh any viewers to
contact their representatives and ask
them to support any efforts to drop the
case against
Julian uh that's a a good final call to
action um for anyone who's worried about
Free Speech the future of press freedom
in America Stella Assange thank you for
talking to reason it's a pleasure thanks
for having
me thanks for listening to just asking
questions these conversations appear on
reason's YouTube channel and Facebook
page every Thursday and the just asking
questions podcast feed every Friday
subscribe wherever you get your podcast
and please rate and review the
show